what do you think guys get wrong about
what women find attractive
okay so I I did a short uh study survey
on on the web about the Giga chat I took
just one photo at most people I think
will know the gigachad this meme
I think he's a very handsome guy but
importantly he's an extremely dimorphic
guy right his face is extremely
masculine big chin big uh brow Ridge and
everything so it's he has an extremely
dimorphic face and he's also considered
to be very handsome at least in these
kind of meme subcultures of the black
pill that's why he's called the Giga
chat because he is kind of the archetype
of the most attractive man so I ran this
across a large sample of men and women
men overwhelmingly related or rated him
as attractive women didn't
but at the same time there was kind of
uh you know it wasn't a distribution
where most women uh
most women found him unattractive but
there were some women who found him
pretty attractive at the same time most
men thought he was attractive so a lot
of the time men kind of get wrong what
women like as far as the physical
features of men I wrote another long
article reviewing uh the research in
that on facial attractiveness and
specifically facial dimorphism masculine
facial features I think men think that
very very masculine facial features are
attractive to women uh usually it isn't
the very most dimorphic basis
that are the most attractive to women if
you think about a really dimorphic face
it's kind of like a gorilla in a sense
uh but it's probably not going to be the
least dimorphic face the least feminine
there's a lot of research on how
averaging this is attractive and
sometimes when I say that people think
what do you mean how can an average face
certainly average is not attractive but
average in this case means features that
are not too extreme that are symmetrical
that are not too extreme so those are
some things that predict uh facial
attractiveness in in any sense for
personality and what I think men often
get wrong at least in kind of these
manosphere subcultures they tend to
think that women enjoy uh anti-social
Behavior
they tend to think that women are very
very attracted to certain anti-social
traits which is typically not the norm
so if you look at something like the
dark Triad for example there is a
research that indicates that the dark
Triad is attracted to women so the dark
Triad is this uh Triad of traits that
are anti-social psychopathy
machiavellianism and narcissism
so looking at those individually
uh some of those actually predict
attractiveness better than others
primarily narcissism and that might be
because people who are narcissists pay
more attention to their own appearance
and because their behavior is very
different it seems like machiavellianism
doesn't actually predict this kind of
attractiveness not attractiveness as far
as physical ratings nor mating success
as well as the other two do so those are
certain things to consider yeah it is
interesting about how the common held
wisdom on the internet about what it is
that women want I had a Seth Stevens
dividowitz on the show who wrote
everybody lies and don't trust your gut
and don't trust your gut he did a
autistic data scientists approach to
optimizing his personal appearance and
he split tested there's websites where
you can do this now but he actually uh
backended this back in the day
um
he grew a beard put a photo of him with
a beard up should I get a beard should I
have glasses should I have my hair short
should I have my hair long should I wear
this should I wear that and he basically
split tested all of the different
iterations of his appearance down to I
should have a beard wear glasses blah
blah this particular like collection of
things uh and he is now by his own
admission in a relationship with a girl
that he's punching out of his league
with and the reason that that happened
he said and he has data to back this up
which is that you want to try and make
people love or hate the um sort of look
that you have going forward you don't
want to be everybody's just okay you
want to be some some people absolutely
go for you and this the same thing goes
for personality as well that he said his
girlfriend uh maybe even now fiance when
they've before they even got together
was with her friends and talking about
being single and they said so what are
you into what are you into what are you
into and they turn to his future
girlfriend so what are you into and she
says I just love nerds I can't say what
it is about it I've just I have so such
a soft spot for nerds and that is the
kind of guy that I find the most sexy
and sure enough down the line comes Seth
Stevens dividowitz ex data scientist at
Google and like literally the guy that's
just done a a spreadsheet to work out
how he should look most attractive but
there you go there's you there's your
your nerdy guy
um now certain corners of the internet
would say oh well you know that's just
her beta books on the way to an alpha
[__] solution or whatever it is
I don't know it it seems to be unlikely
to me because a lot of the time I've
seen guys get into relationships with
girls who really love funny men or
really love artsy men or really love
athletic men or really love whatever
it's not all pointing in this sort of
uni-dimensional one-directional way of
up and across towards hyper masculinity
the higher testosterone you're always
going to win like there's certain
Universal symmetrical face for instance
I've never heard anybody say you know
what it is I just love an unsymmetrical
face that's not something typically that
I've heard but there are far fewer
universalities than I think people would
find and when it comes to guys and
advice for guys in dating I think
becoming uh sticking to some of the
absolute un uh deniable rules and then
going okay what am I what am I really
really good at if you're really really
good at being the The Artsy guy with a
hanging earring that can play the guitar
like yo lean into being Mr guitar player
thing or if you're the super funny guy
you know Pete Davidson's the route to go
whatever it might be you can become more
of what you you are and that to me seems
like
not only the
smartest route to go down in terms of
being effective with women but it's also
the root down which you're going to feel
like less of a fraud and this was
something else that you've brought up
with which is this sort of um pickup
artist to in-cell pipeline that you had
tracked through some data I think one of
the reasons that a lot of guys became
disenchanted with the pickup artist
Community was that what they realized
even the ones that were successful if
you were successful at pickup what it
taught you was that the role that you
played was all that women were attracted
to and the further that the role that
you played was from the person that you
genuinely are you realized oh my God I
am so inherently unlovable and deficient
in myself however women of this game to
be played they're this adversary to be
one that is competitor that I'm supposed
to gain control over and if I play the
game right and use the correct series of
neuro-linguistic programming languages I
will be able to
win this game and for the people who did
try pickup and it didn't work either
because they weren't able to do it
correctly or because there was something
about them that meant that they couldn't
get it to work in no matter what they
did
um it was also dischanting to them too
so pick up to me seemed like a
unfalsifiably
disheartening approach to dating
certainly certainly so what you
mentioned about attractiveness let me
comment on that and then go to the the
pickup because there's two interesting
interesting topics so
a lot of research on facial
attractiveness up to this point has
looked at how much people agree on
attractive faces and when you look at
integrator correlations across a whole
group on attractiveness they seem really
really high you can get correlations
between like 0.6 and 0.9 for facial
attractiveness ratings which makes it
seem like oh man people really agree on
what an attractive face is and it's true
if you look at that metric if you look
within that metric if you run an ICC
correlation and you look at pair ratings
the correlation is much much lower it
can be about 0.2 to 0.3 or so you're
gonna have to explain what you're
talking about here certainly so if you
take a big big group of people and you
have them read a face and you look at
their ratings
then you'll get a correlation that seems
very very high like most people agree on
what an attractive face is
if you take two individual people out of
that group at random and you look at
their correlation and then you take two
more out of that group at random and you
look at their correlation and then you
compute that you'll say wow people don't
really agree at all there's actually a
lot of variation on an attractive face
there's a good paper I think it's from
2016 maybe it's a little older by a
researcher named honeycomb and he plots
it out on a plot and he says okay so
here are all the actual faces and here's
the highest rating and the lowest rating
and almost every face regardless of how
attractive it was got a really high
rating and a really low rating I
recently ran a survey I have it up on
the website now I took faces from the
Chicago face database
and I selected these spaces male and
female faces to be uh kind of below
attractiveness and about all of these
faces got about 25 of people that said
okay that face is good enough I would
date it even though they were all kind
of unattractive faces as far as
pre-ratings went the pre-ratings highly
correlated uh the ratings that people
gave the participants highly correlated
within each other and to these
pre-ratings so people all kind of agreed
on the attractiveness of these spaces
even across different questions that I
asked like how attractive are these
relative to the population how
attractive do you find them at the same
time if you go through all of these
spaces every single one of these spaces
had people that's rated it like you know
a likert scale one through seven seven
most attractive every single face had at
least someone who said it was a seven a
six a five so there is a great deal of
individual variation and attractive face
even if most people agree that a face is
unattractive they're still going to be a
pretty large cohort that says you know I
actually kind of like that face so that
would be maybe Seth the unconventional
or dudes that manages to bag a hottie
because he's exactly what she's looking
for what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]